If you recall from lesson 2, we discussed that we wanted you to become better
critical thinkers. Where critical consumers of research and information. So
let's move onto talk about critical thinking. Critical thinking can be defined
as the process by which we analyze and evaluate the formation of new ideas. So
this is how we analyze facts, how we organize and generate new ideas, how we
defend our opinions and thoughts, how we draw inferences, how we evaluate
arguments, how we make comparisons, and how we solve problems. These are all
examples of critical thinking. So, critical thinking involves analyzing,
interpreting, evaluating, explaining, making inferences, and engaging in
self-regulation. If you can learn these skills, you can become a better
critical thinker. In doing so you examine people's claim by analyzing,
evaluating, and drawing conclusions based on the facts and on the evidence.